a question do you remember
anything we do previously on the show or
do you just
or is it is it like a new is this like
uh you know one of those movies where
adam sandler falls in love with drew
barrymore every day
you even said it was your id you go
let's get backstory before we battle
then you leaned in to start battling and
i had to tell you to tell you not to do
it i don't know if i said before we
battle i just said let's get backstory
we didn't do the chat you forgot the
chance last episode but i'm not even
getting into a battle i'm just gonna i
was gonna say something about saving for
the battle okay that way you don't
repeat yourself four times in the battle
because you're out of material okay how
about that material do you prep yours no
i'm just saying you know you only have
so many points in you and then you start
repeating those points well when you
when you make me take a pull of sativa
that's true i didn't make you do
anything you told me to relax take the
essence off listen baby had a rough day
if it was up to me i'd be blowing lines
of devil's dandruff right now
[Music]
you know